The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ERIK DEMAINE: All right,
let's get started.
Today we're going to continue
the theme of randomization
and data structures.
Last time we saw skip lists.
Skip lists solve the
predecessor-successor problem.
You can search for an item
and if it's not there,
you get the closest item
on either side in log n
with high probability.
But we already knew how to
do that deterministically.
Today we're going to solve a
slightly different problem,
the dictionary problem
with hash tables.
Something you already
think you know.
But we're going to show you
how much you didn't know.
But after today you will know.
And we're going to get
constant time and not
with high probability.
That's hard.
But we'll do constant
expected time.
So that's in some sense better.
It's going to solve
a weaker problem.
But we're going to get
tighter bound constant instead
of logarithmic.
So for starters let me remind
you what problem we're solving
and the basics of hashing
which you learned in 6006.
I'm going to give this problem
a name because it's important
and we often forget
to distinguish
between two types of things.
This is kind of an old
term, but I would call this
an abstract data type.
This is just the
problem specification
of what you're trying to do.
You might call this an
interface or something.
This is the problem statement
versus the data structure
is how you actually solve it.
The hash tables are
the data structure.
The dictionary is the problem
or the abstract data type.
So what we're
trying to do today,
as in most data
structures, is maintain
a dynamic set of items.
And here I'm going to
distinguish between the items
and their keys.
Each item has a key.
And normally you'd
think of there also
being a value like in Python.
But we're just
worrying about the keys
and moving the items around.
And we want to support
three operations.
We want to be able to insert
an item, delete an item,
and search for an item.
But search is going to
be different from what
we know from AVL trees
or skip lists or even
Venom [INAUDIBLE] That was a
predecessor-successor search.
Here we just want
to know-- sorry,
your not searching for an item.
Usually you're searching
for just a key-- here
you just want to know is
there any item with that key,
and return it.
This is often called
an exact search
because if the key
is not in there,
you learn absolutely nothing.
You can't find the nearest key.
And for whatever reason this
is called a dictionary problem
though it's unlike
a real dictionary.
Usually when you search for a
word you do find its neighbors.
Here we're just going to
either-- if the key's there
we find that, otherwise not.
And this is exactly what a
Python dictionary implements.
So I guess that's why Python
dictionaries are called dicts.
So today I'm going to assume
all items have distinct keys.
So in the insertion I will
assume key is not already
in the table.
With a little bit
of work, you can
allow inserting an item
with an existing key,
and you just overwrite
that existing item.
But I don't want to
worry about that here.
So we could, of course,
solve this using an AVL tree
in log n time.
But our goal is to do better
because it's an easier problem.
And I'm going to remind you
of the simplest way you learn
to do this which was hashing
with chaining in 006.
And the catch is you didn't
really analyze this in 006.
So we're going make a
constant time per operation.
It's going to be expected or
something and linear space.
And remember the
variables we care
about, there's u, n, and m.
So u is the size
of the universe.
This is the all possible keys.
The space of all possible keys.
n is the size of the set
your currently storing.
So that's the number
of items or keys
currently in the data structure.
And then m is the
size of your table.
So say it's the number
of slots in the table.
So you remember the picture.
You have a table of slots.
Let's say 0 to m minus 1.
Each of them is a
pointer to a linked list.
And if you have,
let's say over here
is your universe of
all possible keys,
then we have a hash function
which maps each universe
item into one of these slots.
And then the linked
list here is storing
all of the items that
hash to that slot.
So we have a hash function
which maps the universe.
I'm going to assume the
universe has already been mapped
into integers 0 to u minus 1.
And it maps to slots.
And when we do
hashing with chaining,
I think I mentioned this
last week, the bounds
you get, we achieve
a bound of 1 plus
alpha where alpha is
the load factor n/m.
The average number of items
you'd expect to hash to a slot
is the number of items divided
by the number of slots.
OK.
And you proved this
in 6006 but you
assumed something called
simple uniform hashing.
Simple uniform hashing
is an assumption,
I think invented for CLRS.
It makes the
analysis very simple,
but it's also
basically cheating.
So today our goal
is to not cheat.
It's nice as a warm up.
But we don't like cheating.
So you may recall the assumption
is about the hash function.
You want a good hash function.
And good means this.
I want the probability
of two distinct keys
mapping to the same slot to
be 1/m if there are m slots.
If everything was
completely random,
if h was basically choosing a
random number for every key,
then that's what we
would expect to happen.
So this is like the
idealized scenario.
Now, we can't have
a hash function
could choosing a random
number for every key
because it has to choose the
same value if you give it
the same key.
So it has to be some kind
of deterministic strategy
or at least repeatable
strategy where
if you plug in the same
key you get the same thing.
So really what this
assumption is saying
is that the key's that you
give are in some sense random.
If I give you random keys
and I have not-too-crazy hash
function then this will be true.
But I don't like assuming
anything about the keys maybe.
I want my keys to
be worst case maybe.
There are lots of examples in
the real world where you apply
some hash function
and it turns out
your data has some very
particular structure.
And if you choose a
bad hash function,
then your hash table
gets really, really slow.
Maybe everything hashes
to the same slot.
Or say you take--
well yeah, there
are lots of examples of that.
We want to avoid that.
After today you will know how to
achieve constant expected time
no matter what your keys
are, for worst case keys.
But it's going to take
some work to do that.
So this assumption
requires assuming
that the keys are random.
And this is what we would
call an average case analysis.
You might think that
average case analysis is
necessary for
randomized algorithms,
but that's not true.
And we saw that last
week with quicksort.
Quicksort, if you say I
will always choose a of 1
to be my partition
element, that's
what the textbook calls
basic quicksort, then
for an average input
that will do really well.
If you have a uniform
random permutation of items
and you sort with the method of
always choosing the first item
as your partition, then that
will be n log n on average
if your data is average.
But we saw we could
avoid that assumption
by choosing a random pivot.
If you choose a
random pivot, then you
don't need to assume
anything about the input.
You just need to assume
that the pivots are random.
So it's a big difference between
assuming your inputs are random
versus assuming your
coin flips are random.
It's pretty reasonable to
assume you can flip coins.
If you've got enough
dexterity in your thumb then
you can do it.
But it's not so
reasonable to assume
that your input is random.
So we'd like to avoid average
case analysis whenever we can,
and that's the goal of today.
So what you saw in 006 was
essentially assuming the inputs
are random.
We're going to get rid of that
unreasonable assumption today.
So that's, in some
sense, review from 006.
I'm going to take a
brief pause and tell you
about the etymology of the word
hash in case you're curious.
Hash is an English word since
the 1650's, so it's pretty old.
It means literally
cut into small pieces.
It's usually used
in a culinary sense,
like these days you have
corned beef hash or something.
I'll put the
definition over here.
It comes from French, hacher,
which means to chop up.
You know it in English
from the word hatchet.
So it's the same derivation.
And it comes from old French--
I don't actually know whether
that's "hash-ay" or "hash"
but-- which means axe.
So you can see the derivation.
If you look this
up in OED or pick
your favorite dictionary or even
Google, that's what you find.
But in fact there's a
new prevailing theory
that in fact hash comes
from another language which
is Vulcan, la'ash, I mean you
can see the derivation right?
Actually means axe.
So maybe French got it
from Vulcan or vice versa
but I think that's pretty clear.
Live long and prosper,
and farewell to Spock.
Sad news of last week.
So enough about hashing.
We'll come back to
that in a little bit.
But hash functions
essentially take up
this idea of taking your
key, chopping up into pieces,
and mixing it like
in a good dish.
All right, so we're going
to cover two ways to get
strong constant time bounds.
Probably the most useful one
is called universal hashing.
We'll spend most of
our time on that.
But the theoretically cooler
one is called perfect hashing.
Universal hashing,
we're going to guarantee
there are very few
conflicts in expectation.
Perfect hashing , we're going
to guarantee there are zero
conflicts.
The catch is, at least
in its obvious form,
it only works for static sets.
If you forbid, insert,
and delete and just want
to do search, then perfect
hashing is a good method.
So like if you're
actually storing
a dictionary, like
the OED, English
doesn't change that quickly.
So you can afford to recompute
your data structure whenever
you release a new edition.
But let's start with
universal hashing.
This is a nice
powerful technique.
It works for dynamic data.
Insert, delete, and
search will be constant
expected time with no
assumptions about the input.
So it will not be average case.
It's in some sense worse
case but randomized.
So the idea is we need
to do something random.
If you just say, well, I
choose one hash function
once and for all, and I
use that for my table,
OK maybe my table
doubles in size
and I change the hash function.
But there's no randomness there.
We need to introduce
randomness somehow
into this data structure.
And the way we're
going to do that
is in how we choose
the hash function.
We're going to choose our
hash function randomly
from some set of hash functions.
Call it h.
This is going to be a
universal hash family.
We're going to imagine
there are many possible hash
functions we could choose.
If we choose one of them
uniformly at random,
that's a random choice.
And that randomness
is going to be enough
that we no longer need to
assume anything about the keys.
So for that to work, we need
some assumption about h.
Maybe it's just a set
of one hash function.
That wouldn't add
much randomness.
Two also would not
add much randomness.
We need a lot of them.
And so we're going to require
H to have this property.
And we're going to call it
the property universality.
Generally you would call
it a universal hash family.
Just a set of hash functions.
What we want is that-- so we're
choosing our hash function
h from H. And
among those choices
we want the probability that
two keys hash to the same value
to be small.
I'll say-- and this
is very similar
looking to simple
uniform hashing.
Looks almost the same here
except I switched from k1
and k2 to k and
k', but same thing.
But what we're taking
the probability over,
what we're assuming is
random is different.
Here we're assuming k1 and
k2 a are because h was fixed.
This was an assumption
about the inputs.
Over here we're thinking
of k and k' as being fixed.
This has to work for every
pair of distinct keys.
And the probability
we're considering
is the distribution of h.
So we're trying all the
different h's Or we're trying
little h uniformly at random.
We want the probability that a
random h makes k and k' collide
to be at most 1/m.
The other difference is we
switch from equals to at most.
I mean less would be better.
And there are ways to make
it less for a couple pairs
but it doesn't really matter.
But of course anything
less than or equal to 1/m
will be just as good.
So this is an
assumption about H.
We'll see how to achieve this
assumption in a little bit.
Let me first prove to
you that this is enough.
It's going to be basically
the same as the 006 analysis.
But it's worth repeating just
so we are sure everything's OK.
And so I can be more precise
about what we're assuming.
The key difference between this
theorem and the 006 theorem is
we get to make no
assumptions about the keys.
They are arbitrary.
You get to choose
them however you want.
But then I choose a
random hash function.
The hash function cannot
depend on these keys.
But it's going to be random.
And I choose the hash function
after you choose the keys.
That's important.
So we're going to
choose a random h and H.
And we're assuming
H is universal.
Then the expected number of keys
in a slot among those n keys
is at most 1 plus alpha.
Alpha is n/m.
So this is exactly
what we had over here.
Here we're talking
about time bound.
But the time bound
followed because the length
of each chain was expected
to be 1 plus alpha.
And here the expectation
is over the choice of h.
Not assuming anything
about the keys.
So let's prove this theorem.
It's pretty easy.
But I'm going to introduce
some analysis techniques
that we will use for
more interesting things.
So let's give the keys a name.
I'll just call
them-- I'll be lazy.
Use k1 up to kn.
And I just want to
compute that expectation.
So I want to compute let's say
the number of keys colliding
with one of those
keys, let's say ki.
So this is of course the size of
the slot that ki happens to go.
This is going to work for all i.
And so if I can say that this
is at most 1/alpha for each i,
then I have my theorem.
Just another way
to talk about it.
Now the number of keys
colliding with ki, here's
a general trick, whenever
you want to count something
in expectation, a
very helpful tool
is indicator random variables.
Let's name all of the different
events that we want to count.
And then we're basically
summing those variables.
So I'm going to say-- I'm going
to use I ij to be an indicator
random variable.
It's going to be 1 or 0.
1 if hash function of ki
equals the hash function of kj.
So there's a collision
between ki and kj j and 0
if they hash to different slots.
Now this is, it's a random
variable because it depends
on h and h is a random thing.
ki and kj are not random.
They're given to you.
And then I want to know
when does h back those two
keys to the same slot.
And so this number is really
just the sum of Iij over all j.
This is the same thing.
The number in here is the sum
for j not equal to i of Iij.
Because we get a 1 every time
they collide, zero otherwise.
So that counts how many collide.
Once we have it
in this notation,
we can use all the great
dilemmas and theorems
about in this case,
E, expectation.
What should I use here?
STUDENT: What?
ERIK DEMAINE: What's
a good-- how can I
simplify this formula?
STUDENT: The linearity
of expectation.
ERIK DEMAINE: The
linearity of expectation.
Thank you.
If you don't know
all these things,
read the probability
appendix in the textbook.
So we want to talk
about expectation
of the simplest thing possible.
So linearity let's us
put the E inside the sum
without losing anything.
Now the expectation of an
indicator random variable
is pretty simple
because the zeros don't
contribute to the expectation.
The 1's contribute 1.
So this is the same thing
as just the probability
of this being 1.
So we get sum of j9 equal
to I of the probability
that Iij equals 1.
And the probability
that Iij equals 1,
well, that's the probability
that this happens.
And what's the probability
that that happens?
At most 1/m our universality.
So I'm going to--
I'll write it out.
This is sum j not
equal to I. Probability
that h maps ki and
kj to the same slot.
So that's the definition of Iij.
And this is at most
sum j not equal to i
of 1/m by universality.
So here's where we're using it.
And sum of j not equal to
I, well that's basically n.
But I made a mistake here.
Slightly off.
From here-- yeah.
So this line is wrong.
Sorry.
Let me fix it.
Because this
assumption only works
when the keys are distinct.
So in fact-- how did I get
j-- yeah. , Yeah, sorry.
This should have been
this-- actually everything
I said is true, but if you want
to count the number of keys--
I really wanted to count the
total number of keys that
hash to the same place as ki.
So there's one more
which is ki itself.
Always hashes to
wherever ki hashes.
So I did a summation
j not equal i
but I should also have
a plus Iii-- captain.
So there's the case when I
hashing to the same place which
of course is always going to
happen so you get basically
plus 1 everywhere.
So that makes me
happier because then I
actually get with the theorem
said which is 1 plus alpha.
There is always going to be
the one guy hashing there
when I assume that ki
hashed to wherever it does.
So this tells you that if we
could find a universal hash
family, then we're guaranteed
insert, delete, and search
cost order 1 plus
alpha in expectation.
And the expectation is
only over the choice of h,
not over the inputs.
I think I've stressed
that enough times.
But the remaining question
is can we actually
design a universal hash family?
Are there any universal
hash families?
Yes, as you might
expect there are.
Otherwise this wouldn't
be very interesting.
Let me give you an example of
a bad universal hash family.
Sort of an oxymoron
but it's possible.
Bad.
Here's a hash family
that's universal.
h is the set of
all hash functions.
h from 0,1 to u minus 1.
This is what's normally
called uniform hashing.
It makes analysis
really easy because you
get to assume-- I
mean this says ahead
of time for every
universe item, I'm
going to choose a
random slot to put it.
And then I'll just
remember that.
And so whenever you give me
the key, I'll just map it by h.
And I get a consistent slot
and definitely it's universal.
What's bad about
this hash function?
Many things but--
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] That's
just as hard as the problem I'm
solving.
ERIK DEMAINE: Sort of.
I'm begging the
question that it's just
as hard as the
problem I'm solving.
And what, algorithmically,
what goes wrong here?
There are two things I guess.
Yeah?
STUDENT: It's not deterministic?
ERIK DEMAINE: It's
not deterministic.
That's OK because we're
allowing randomization
in this algorithm.
So I mean how I
would compute this
is I would do a four loop
over all universe items.
And I assume I have a way
to generate a random number
between 0 and m minus 1.
That's legitimate.
But there's something
bad about that algorithm.
STUDENT: It's not consistent.
ERIK DEMAINE: Not consistent?
It is consistent if I precompute
for every universe item
where to map it.
That's good.
So all these things
are actually OK.
STUDENT: It takes too
much time and space.
ERIK DEMAINE: It takes
too much time and space.
Yeah.
That's the bad thing.
It's hard to isolate in a bad
thing what is so bad about it.
But we need u time to compute
all those random numbers.
And we need u space to
store that hash function.
In order to get to the
consistency we have to-- Oops.
Good catch.
In order to get
consistency, we need
to keep track of all those
hash function values.
And that's not good.
You could try to not
store them all, you know,
use a hash table.
But you can't use a hash table
to store a hash function.
That would be-- that would
be infinite recursion.
So but at least
they're out there.
So the challenge is to find
an efficient hash family that
doesn't take much space
to store and doesn't
take much time to compute.
OK, we're allowing randomness.
But we don't want
to much randomness.
We can't afford u units
of time of randomness.
I mean u could be huge.
We're only doing n operations
probably on this hash table.
u could be way bigger than n.
We don't want to have to
precompute this giant table
and then use it for
like five steps.
It would be really, really
slow even amortized.
So here's one that
I will analyze.
And there's another one in the
textbook which I'll mention.
This one's a little
bit simpler to analyze.
We're going to need a little
bit of number theory, just
prime numbers.
And you've probably heard of
the idea of your hash table size
being prime.
Here you'll see
why that's useful,
at least for this family.
You don't always need
primality, but it's
going to make this family work.
So I'm going to assume that
my table size is prime.
Now really my table
size is doubling,
so that's a little awkward.
But luckily there are
algorithms given a number
to find a nearby prime number.
We're not going to
cover that here,
but that's an algorithmic
number theory thing.
And in polylogarithmic
time, I guess
you can find a
nearby prime number.
So you want it to
be a power of 2.
And you'll just look around
for nearby prime numbers.
And then we have a prime that's
about the same size so that
will work just as well from
a table doubling perspective.
Then furthermore,
for convenience,
I'm going to assume that u
is an integer power of m.
I want my universe to be
a power of that prime.
I mean, if it isn't, just
make u a little bigger.
It's OK if u gets
bigger as long as it
covers all of the same items.
Now once I view my universe
as a power of the table size,
a natural thing to do is
take my universe items,
to take my input integers,
and think of them in base m.
So that's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to view
a key k in base m.
Whenever I have a
key, I can think of it
as a vector of subkeys,
k1 up to kr minus 1.
There are digits in base m
because of this relation.
And I don't even care which
is the least significant
and which is the
most significant.
That won't matter so
whatever, whichever order
you want to think of it.
And each of the
ki's here I guess
is between 0 and m minus 1.
So far so good.
So with this perspective,
the base m perspective,
I can define a dot product
hash function as follows.
It's going to be
parametrized by another key,
I'll call it a, which we can
think of again as a vector.
I want to define h sub a of k.
So this is parametrized
by a, but it's
a function of a given
key k as the dot product
of those two vectors mod m.
So remember dot products
are just the sum from i
equals 0 to r minus
1 of a1 times ki.
I want to do all
of that modulo m.
We'll worry about
how long this takes
to compute in a moment I guess.
Maybe very soon.
But the hash family h is
just all of these ha's
for all possible choices of a.
a was a key so it comes
from the universe u.
And so what that means is
to do universal hashing,
I want to choose one of these
ha's uniformly at random.
How do I do that?
I just choose a
uniformly at random.
Pretty easy.
It's one random value
from one random key.
So that should take constant
time and constant space
to store one number.
In general we're in a world
called the Word RAM model.
This is actually-- I
guess m stands for model
so I shouldn't write model.
Random access machine
which you may have heard.
The word RAM assumes
that in general we're
manipulating integers.
And the integers fit in a word.
And the computational
assumption is
that manipulating a
constant number of words
and doing essentially
any operation you
want on constant number of
words takes constant time.
And the other part
of the word RAM model
is to assume that the things
you care about fit in a word.
Say individual data values,
here we're talking about keys,
fit in a word.
This is what you need
to assume in [INAUDIBLE]
that you can compute high
of x in constant time or low
of x in constant time.
Here I'm going to use it to
assume that we can compute
h sub a of k in constant time.
In practice this would
be done by implementing
this computation, this
dot product computation,
in hardware.
And the reason a 64-bit
edition on a modern processor
or a 32-bit on most
phones takes constant time
is because there's
hardware that's designed
to do that really fast.
And in general we're assuming
that the things we care about
fit in a single word.
And we're assuming random access
and that we can have a raise.
That's what we need in
order to store a table.
And same thing in [INAUDIBLE],
we needed to assume we
had a raise.
And I think this
operation is actually
pretty-- exists in Intel
architectures in some form.
But it's certainly not
a normal operation.
If you're going to
do this explicitly,
adding up and
multiplying things this
would be r is the log base m of
u, so it's kind of logish time.
Maybe I'll mention
another hash family that's
more obviously computable.
But I won't analyze here.
It's analyzed in the textbook.
So if you're curious you
can check it out there.
Let's call this just another.
It's a bit weird
because it has two mods.
You take mod p and then mod m.
But the main computation
is very simple.
You choose a uniformly
random value a.
You multiply it by your key
in usual binary multiplication
instead of dot product.
And then you add another
uniformly random key.
This is also universal.
So H is hab for all a
and b that are keys.
So if you're not happy
with this assumption
that you can compute
this in constant time,
you should be happy
with this assumption.
If you believe in addition and
multiplication and division
being constant time, then
this will be constant time.
So both of these
families are universal.
I'm going to prove that this
one is universal because it's
a little bit easier.
Yeah?
STUDENT: Is this p a
choice that you made?
ERIK DEMAINE: OK, right.
What is p?
P just has to be bigger than
m, and it should be prime.
It's not random.
You can just choose one prime
that's bigger than your table
size, and this will work.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: I
forget whether you
have to assume that m is prime.
I'd have to check.
I'm guessing not, but
don't quote me on that.
Check the section
in the textbook.
So good.
Easy to compute.
The analysis is simpler, but
it's a little bit easier here.
Essentially this is
very much like products
but there's no
carries here from one.
When we do the dot product
instead of just multiplying
in base m we multiply
them based on that
would give the same thing
as multiplying in base 2,
but we get carries from one
m-sized digit to the next one.
And that's just more
annoying to think about.
So here we're essentially
getting rid of carries.
So it's in some sense
even easier to compute.
And in both cases,
it's universal.
So we want to prove
this property.
That if we choose a random
a then the probability
of two keys, k and k'
which are distinct mapping
via h to the same value is at
most 1/m So let's prove that.
So we're given two keys.
We have no control
over them because this
has to work for all
keys that are distinct.
The only thing we know
is that they're distinct.
Now if two keys are
distinct, then their vectors
must be distinct.
If two vectors
are distinct, that
means at least one
item must be different.
Should sound familiar.
So this was like in the matrix
multiplication verification
algorithm that
[INAUDIBLE] taught.
So k and k' differ
in some digit.
Let's call that digit d.
So k sub d is different
from k sub d'.
And I want to compute
this probability.
We'll rewrite it.
The probability is over a.
I'm choosing a
uniformly at random.
I want another
probability that that
maps k and k' to the same slot.
So let me just write
out the definition.
It's probability over a that
the dot product of a and k
is the same thing as when I do
the dot product with k' mod m.
These two, that sum should
come out the same, mod m.
So let me move this part over to
this side because in both cases
we have the same ai.
So I can group
terms and say this
is the probability--
probability sum over i
equals 0 to r minus 1
of ai times ki minus
ki prime equals 0.
Mod m.
OK, no pun intended.
Now we care about this digit d.
d is a place where we know
that this is non-zero.
So let me separate out the terms
for d and everything but d.
So this is the same as ability
of, let's do the d term first,
so we have ad times
kd minus kd prime.
That's one term.
I'm going to write
the summation of i
not equal to d of ai
ki minus ki prime.
These ones, some of
them might be zero.
Some are not.
We're not going
to worry about it.
It's enough to just isolate
one term that is non-zero.
So this thing we know
does not equal zero.
Cool.
Here's where I'm going to use
a little bit of number theory.
I haven't yet used
that m is prime.
I required m is prime because
when you're working modulo m,
you have multiplicative
inverses.
Because this is
not zero, there is
something I can
multiply on both sides
and get this to cancel
out and become one.
For every value x
there is a value y.
So x times y equals 1 modulo m.
And you can even compute
it in constant time
in a reasonable model.
So then I can say I want the
probability that ad is minus
kd minus kd prime inverse.
This is the multiplicative
inverse I was talking about.
And then the sum i not equal
to d whatever, I don't actually
care what this is too much, I've
already done the equals part.
I still need to write mod m.
The point is this
is all about ad.
Remember we're choosing
a uniformly at random.
That's the same
thing as choosing
each of the ai's independently
uniformly at random.
Yeah?
STUDENT: Is the second line over
there isolating d [INAUDIBLE]?
Second from the top.
ERIK DEMAINE: Which?
This one?
STUDENT: No up.
ERIK DEMAINE: This?
STUDENT: Down.
That one.
No.
The one below that.
ERIK DEMAINE: Yes.
STUDENT: Is that line
isolating d or is that--
ERIK DEMAINE: No.
I haven't isolated d yet.
This is all the terms.
And then going from
this line to this one,
I'm just pulling out
the i equals d term.
That's this term.
And then separating out
the i not equal to d.
STUDENT: I get it.
ERIK DEMAINE: Right?
This sum is just the
same as that sum.
But I've done the
d term explicitly.
STUDENT: Sure.
I get it.
ERIK DEMAINE: So I've
done all this rewriting
because I know that ad is
chosen uniformly at random.
Here we have this
thing, this monstrosity,
but it does not depend on ad.
In fact it is independent of ad.
I'm going to write this
as a function of k and k'
because those are
given to us and fixed.
And then it's also a
function of a0 and a1.
Everything except d.
So ad minus 1, ad plus 1,
and so on up to ar minus 1.
This is awkward to write.
But everything except
ad appears here
because we have
i not equal to d.
And these ai's are
random variables.
But we're assuming that they're
all chosen independently
from each other.
So I don't really care what's
going on in this function.
It's something.
And if I rewrite
this probability,
it's the probability
over the choice of a.
I can separate out the
choice of all these things
from the choice of ad.
And this is just
a useful formula.
I'm going to write
a not equal to d.
All the other-- maybe I'll
write a sub i not equal to d.
All the choices of
those guys separately
from the probability
of choosing ad of ad
equal to this function.
If you just think about the
definition of expectation,
this is doing the same thing.
We're thinking of first
choosing the ai's where
i is not equal to d.
And then we choose ad.
And this computational will
come out the same as that.
But this is the probability
of a uniformly random number
equaling something.
So we just need to
think about-- sorry.
Important.
That would be pretty
unlikely that would be 1/u,
but this is all
working modulo m.
So if I just take a
uniformly random integer
and the chance of it hitting any
particular value mod m is 1/m.
And that's universality.
So in this case, you get exactly
1/m, no less than or equal to.
Sorry, I should have written
it's the expectation of 1/m,
but that's 1/m because 1/m
has no random parts in it.
Yeah?
STUDENT: How do
we know that the,
that this expression doesn't
have any biases in the sense
that it doesn't give more,
more, like if you give it
the uniform
distribution of numbers,
it doesn't spit out
more numbers than others
and that could potentially--
ERIK DEMAINE: Oh,
so you're asking
how do we know that
this hash family doesn't
prefer some slots
over others, I guess.
STUDENT: Of course like
after the equals sign,
like in this middle
line in the middle.
Middle board.
ERIK DEMAINE: This one?
Oh, this one.
STUDENT: Middle board.
ERIK DEMAINE: Middle board.
Here.
STUDENT: Yes.
So how do we know
that if you give it--
ERIK DEMAINE: This function.
STUDENT: --random variables,
it won't prefer certain numbers
over others?
ERIK DEMAINE: So this function
may prefer some numbers
over others.
But it doesn't matter.
All we need is
that this function
is independent of
our choice of ad.
So you can think
of this function,
you choose all of these
random-- actually k and k'
are not random-- but you choose
all these random numbers.
Then you evaluate your f.
Maybe it always comes out to 5.
Who knows.
It could be super biased.
But then you choose ad
uniformly at random.
So the chance of ad
equalling 5 is the same
as the chance of ad equaling 3.
So in all cases, you get
the probability is 1/m.
What we need is independence.
We need that the ad is chosen
independently from the other
ai's.
But we don't need to know
anything about f other
than it doesn't depend on ad.
So and we made it not depend
on ad because I isolated ad
by pulling it out
of that summation.
So we know there's
no ad's over here.
Good question.
You get a bonus Frisbee
for your question.
All right.
That ends universal hashing.
Any more questions?
So at this point we
have at least one
universal hash family.
So we're just choosing, in this
case, a uniformly at random.
In the other method, we choose
a and b uniformly at random.
And then we build
our hash table.
And the hash function
depends on m.
So also every time we
double our table size,
we're going to have to
choose a new hash function
for the new value of m.
And that's about it.
So this will give us constant
expected time-- or in general 1
plus alpha if you're not doing
table doubling-- for insert,
delete, and exact search.
Just building on the
hashing with chaining.
And so this is a good method.
Question?
STUDENT: Why do you say expected
value of the probability?
Isn't it sufficient to just say
the probability of [INAUDIBLE]?
ERIK DEMAINE: Uh, yeah,
I wanted to isolate--
it is the overall probability
of this happening.
I rewrote it this
way because I wanted
to think about first choosing
the ai's where i does not
equal d and then choosing ad.
So this probability
was supposed to be only
over the choice of ad.
And you have to do something
with the other ai's
because they're random.
You can't just say,
what's the probability ad
equaling a random variable?
That's a little sketchy.
I wanted to have no
random variables over all.
So I have to kind of bind
those variables with something.
And I just want to see what
the-- This doesn't really
affect very much, but to
make this algebraically
correct I need to say
what the ai's, i not
equal to d are doing.
Other questions?
Yeah.
STUDENT: Um, I'm a bit
confused about your definition
of the collision in
the lower left board.
Why are you adding
i's [INAUDIBLE]?
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah, sorry.
This is a funny
notion of colliding.
I just mean I want to count
the number of keys that
hash to the same slot as ki.
STUDENT: So it's not necessarily
like a collision [INAUDIBLE].
ERIK DEMAINE: You
may not call it
a collision when it
collides with itself, yeah.
Whatever you want to call it.
But I just mean hashing
to the same slot is ki.
Yeah.
Just because I want to count
the total length of the chain.
I don't want to count the number
of collisions in the chain.
Sorry.
Probably a poor choice of word.
We're hashing because
we're taking our key,
we're cutting it up
into little bits,
and then we're mixing them up
just like a good corned beef
hash or something.
All right let's move
on to perfect hashing.
This is more
exciting I would say.
Even cooler-- this was cool
from a probability perspective,
depending on your
notion of cool.
This method will be cool from
a data structures perspective
and a probability perspective.
But so far data structures
are what we know from 006.
Now we're going to go
up a level, literally.
We're going to have two levels.
So here we're solving-- you
can actually make this data
structure dynamic.
But we're going to solve
the static dictionary
problem which is when you
have no inserts and deletes.
You're given the keys up front.
You're given n keys.
You want to build a table
that supports search.
And that's it.
You want search to
be constant time
and perfect hashing,
also known as FKS hashing
because it was invented by
Fredman, Komlos, and Szemeredi
in 1984.
What we will achieve is constant
time worst case for search.
So that's a little
better because here we're
just doing constant
expected time for search.
But it's worse in that we have
to know the keys up in advance.
We're going to take the linear
space in the worst case.
And then the
remaining question is
how long does it take you to
build this data structure?
And for now I'll just
say it's polynomial time.
It's actually going
to be nearly linear.
And this is also
an expected bounds.
Actually with high probability
could be a little more strong
here.
So it's going to take
us a little bit of time
to build this structure,
but once you have it,
you have the perfect scenario.
There's going to
be in some sense
no collisions in our hash
table so it would be constant
times first search
and linear space.
So that part's great.
The only catch is it's static.
But beggars can't
be choosers I guess.
All right.
I'm not sure who's begging
in that analogy but.
The keys who want to be stored.
I don't know.
All right, so the big
idea for perfect hashing
is to use two levels.
So let me draw a picture.
We have our universe, and we're
mapping that via hash function
h1 into a table.
Look familiar?
Exactly the diagram
I drew before.
It's going to have
some table size m.
And we're going to set m to be
within a constant factor of n.
So right now it looks
exactly like regular--
and it's going to
be a universal,
h1 is chosen from a
universal hash family,
so universal hashing applies.
The trouble is we're going
to get some lists here.
And we don't want to store
the set of colliding elements,
the set of elements that hash to
that place, with a linked list
because linked lists are slow.
Instead we're going to store
them using a hash table.
It sounds crazy.
But we're going to have--
so this is position 1.
This is going to be h2,1.
There's going to be another hash
function h2,0 that maps to some
other hash table.
These hash tables are going
to be of varying sizes.
Some of them will be of size 0
because nothing hashes there.
But in general
each of these slots
is going to map instead of to
a linked list to a hash table.
So this would be h2, m minus 1.
I'm going to guarantee in
the second level of hashing
there are zero collisions.
Let that sink in a little bit.
Let me write down a little
more carefully what I'm doing.
So h1 is picked from a
universal hash family.
Where m is theta n.
I want to put a theta-- I
mean I could m equals n,
but sometimes we
require m to be a prime.
So I'm going to give you some
slop in how you choose m.
So it can be prime
or whatever you want.
And then at the
first level we're
basically doing
hashing with chaining.
And now I want to look at
each slot in that hash table.
So between 0 and m-1.
I'm going to let lj be the
number of keys that hash,
it's the length of the
list that would go there.
It's going to be
the number of keys,
among just the n keys, Number
of, keys hashing to slot j.
So now the big question
is, if I have lj keys here,
how big do I make that table?
You might say, well
I make a theta lj.
That's what I always do.
But that's not what
I'm going to do.
That wouldn't help.
We get exactly, I
think, the same number
of collisions if we did that,
more or less, in expectation.
So we're going do
something else.
We're going to pick a hash
function from a universal
family, h2,j.
It again maps the same universe.
The key thing is the
size of the hash table
I'm going to choose
which is lj squared.
So if there are 3 elements that
happen to hash to this slot,
this table will have size 9.
So it's mostly empty.
Only square root fraction--
if that's a word, if that's
a phrase-- will be full.
Most of it's empty.
Why squared?
Any ideas?
I claim this will guarantee zero
collisions with decent chance.
Yeah.
STUDENT: With 1/2
probability you're
going to end up
with no collisions.
ERIK DEMAINE: With
1/2 probability
I'm going to end up
with no collisions.
Why?
What's it called?
STUDENT: Markov [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: Markov's
inequality would prove it.
But it's more commonly
known as the, whoa,
as the birthday paradox.
So the whole name of the game
here is the birthday paradox.
If I have, how's
it go, if I have n
squared people with n
possible birthdays then--
is that the right way?
No, less.
If I have n people and n
squared possible birthdays,
the probability of getting a
collision, a shared birthday,
is 1/2.
Normally we think of
that as a funny thing.
You know, if I choose a
fair number of people,
then I get immediately
a collision.
I'm going to do it
the opposite way.
I'm going to guarantee that
there's so many birthdays
that no 2 of them will collide
with probability of 1/2 No,
1/2 is not great.
We're going to fix that.
So actually I haven't given
you the whole algorithm yet.
There are two steps, 1 and 2.
But there are also two
other steps 1.5 and 2.5.
But this is the right
idea and this will make
things work in expectation.
But I'm going to
tweak it a little bit.
So first let me
tell you step 1.5.
It fits in between the two.
I want that the space of this
data structure is linear.
So I need to make sure it is.
If the sum j equals 0 to
m minus 1 of lj squared
is bigger than
some constant times
n-- we'll figure out what the
constant is later-- then redo
step 1.
So after I do step 1, I know
how big all these tables
are going to be.
If the sum of those squares is
bigger than linear, start over.
I need to prove
that this will only
have to take-- this
will happen an expected
constant number of times.
log n times with
high probability.
In fact why don't we-- yeah,
let's worry about that later.
Let me first tell
you step 2.5 which
is I want there to be
zero collisions in each
of these tables.
It's only going to happen
with probability of 1/2
So if it doesn't
happen, just try again.
So 2.5 is while there's some
hash function h2,j that maps 2
keys that we're given to the
same slot at the second level,
this is for some j and let's
say ki different from ki prime.
But they map to the same place
by the first hash function.
So if two keys map to
the same secondary table
and there's a
conflict, then I'm just
going to redo that construction.
So I'm going to repick h2,j.
h2,j was a random choice.
So if I get a bad choice,
I'll just try another one.
Just keep randomly
choosing the a
or randomly choosing
this hash function
until there are zero collisions
in that secondary table.
And I'm going to do
this for each table.
So we worry about how
long these will take,
but I claim expected
constant number of trials.
So let's do the
second one first.
After we do this y loop
there are no collisions
with the proper notion of
the word collisions, which
is two different keys
mapping to the same value.
So at this point
we have guaranteed
that searches are
constant time worst
case after we do all these
4 steps because we apply h1,
we figure out which
slot we fit in.
Say it's slot j,
then we apply h2j
and if your item's
in the overall table,
it should be in that
secondary table.
Because there are no
collisions you can see,
is that one item the
one I'm looking for?
If so, return it.
If not, it's not anywhere.
If there are no
collisions then I
don't need chains coming out
of here because it is just
a single item.
The big question-- so
constant worst case space
because 1.5 guarantees that.
Constant worst case
time first search.
The big question is, how
long does it take to build?
How many times do
we have to redo
steps 1 and 2 before we
get a decent-- before we
get a perfect hash table.
So let me remind
you of the birthday
paradox, why it works here.
As mentioned earlier this is
going to be a union bounds.
We want to know the
probability of collision
at that second level.
Well that's at most the sum
of all possible collisions,
probabilities of collisions.
So I'm going to say
the sum over all i
not equal to ij of
the probability.
Now this is over our choice
of the hash function h2,j.
Of h2,j of ki equaling
h2,j of ki prime.
So union bounds says, of course.
The probability of any
of them happening--
we don't know about
interdependence or whatnot--
but certainly almost the sum of
each of these possible events.
There are a lot of
possible events.
If there 's li
things, that there
are going to be li choose
2 possible collisions
we have to worry about.
We know i is not
equal to i prime.
So the number of terms
here is li choose 2.
And what's this probability?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: 1/li at most
because we're assuming h2,j is
a universal hash function so
the probability of choosing--
sorry?
li squared.
Thank you.
The size of the table.
1/m but m in this case, the
size of our table is li squared.
So the probability that we
choose a good hash function
and that these
particular keys don't hit
is at most 1/li squared.
This is basically li squared/ 2.
And so this is at most 1/2.
It's a slightly less
than li squared/2.
So this is at most 1/2.
And this is basically
a birthday paradox
in this particular case.
That means there
is a probability
of at least a half that there
is zero collisions in one
of these tables.
So that means I'm basically
flipping a fair coin.
If I ever get a heads I'm happy.
Each time I get a
tails I have to reflip.
This should sound
familiar from last time.
So this is 2 expected trials
or log n with high probability.
We've proved log n
with high probability.
That's the same as saying the
number of levels in a skip list
is log n with high probability.
How many times do I have to flip
a coin before I get a heads?
Definitely at most log n.
Now we have to do this
for each secondary table.
There are m equal theta
and secondary tables.
There's a slight question of how
big are the secondary tables.
If one of these tables
is like linear size,
then I have to spend
linear time for a trial.
And then I multiply that
by the number of trials
and also the number of different
things that would be like n
squared log n n.
But you know a secondary table
better not have linear sides.
I mean a linear
number of li equal n.
That would be bad because
then li squared is n squared
and we guaranteed that
we had linear space.
So in fact you can prove
with another Chernoff bound.
Let me put this over here.
That all the li's
are pretty small.
Not constant but logarithmic.
So li is order log n with
high probability for each i
and therefore for all i.
So I can just change the alpha
my minus 1 n to the alpha
and get that for
all i this happens.
In fact, the right answer
is log over log log,
if you want to do some
really messy analysis.
But we just, logarithmic
is fine for us.
So what this means
is we're doing
n different things
for each of them
with high probability
li is of size log n.
And then maybe we'll have
to do like log n trials
repeating until we get a
good hash function there.
And so the total build
time for steps 1 and 2.5
is going to be at most
n times log squared n.
You can prove a tighter
bound but it's polynomial.
That's all I wanted to go
for and it's almost linear.
So I'm left with one thing
to analyze which is step 1.5.
This to me is maybe the
most surprising thing
that it works out.
I mean here we designed--
we did this li to li
squared so the birthday
paradox would happen.
This is not surprising.
I mean it's a cool idea,
but once you have the idea,
it's not surprising
that it works.
What's a little more
surprising is that squaring
is OK from a space perspective.
1.5 says we're going
to have to rebuild
that first table until the
sum of these squared lengths
is at most linear.
I can guarantee
that each of these
is logarithmic so the sum of the
squares is at most like n log
squared n.
But I claim I can get linear.
Let's do that.
So for step 1.5
we're looking at what
is the expectation of the
sum of the lj squareds being
more than linear.
Sorry.
Expectation.
Let's first compute
the expectation
and then we'll talk
about a tail bound
which is the probability
that we're much
bigger than the expectation.
First thing is I claim
the expectation is linear.
So again whenever we're
counting something--
I mean this is basically
the total number of pairs
of items that collide
at the first level
with double counting.
So I mean if you think of lj
and then I make a complete graph
on those lj items,
that's going to have
like the squared
number of edges, so,
if I also multiply by 2.
So this is the same
thing as counting
how many pairs of items map to
the same spot, the same slot.
So this is going to-- and that
I can write as an indicator
random variable which
lets me use linearity
of expectation
which makes me happy
because then everything simple.
So I'm going to write Ii,j.
This is going to be 1 if each 1
of ki, I guess, equals h1 if kj
and it's going to be
0 if h1 otherwise.
This is the total number
of pairwise colliding
items including i versus i.
And so like if li equals
1, li squared is also 1.
There's 1 item
colliding with itself.
So this actually works exactly.
All right, with the wrong
definition of colliding.
If you bear with me.
So now we can use
linear of expectation
and put the E in here.
So this is sum i equals 1
to n sum j equals 1 to n
of the expectation of Ii,j.
But we know the expectation
of the Ii,j is the probability
of it equaling 1 because it's
an indicator random variable.
The probability of this
happening over our choice of h1
is at most 1/m by universality.
Here it actually is m because
we're at the first level.
So this is at most
1/m which is theta n.
So when i does not equal j,
so it's a little bit annoying.
I do have to separate out the Ii
terms from the i and different
i not equal to j terms.
But there's only-- I
mean it's basically
the diagonal of this matrix.
There's n things that will
always collide with themselves.
So we're going to get like
n plus the number of i
not equal to pairs
double counted.
So it's like 2 times n choose 2.
But we get to divide by m.
So this is like n squared /n.
So we get order n.
So that's not--
well, that's cool.
Expected space is linear.
This is what makes
everything work.
Last class was about getting
with high probability bounds
when we're working with logs.
When you want to
get that something
is log with high
probability, you
have to use, with
respect to n, you
have to use a turn off bound.
But this is about-- now I
want to show that the space is
linear with high probability.
Linear is actually really easy.
You can use a much weaker
bound called Markov inequality.
So I want to claim that the
probability of h1 of this thing
lj squareds being bigger
than some constant times
n is at most the expectation
of that thing divided by cn.
This is Markov's inequality.
It holds for anything here.
So I'm just repeating
it over here.
So this is nice because we
know that this expectation is
linear.
So we're getting like a
linear function divided by cn.
Remember we get to choose c.
The step said if it's bigger
than some constant times n
then we're redoing the thing.
So I can choose c
to be 100, whatever.
I'm going to choose it to
be twice this constant.
And then this is at most half.
So the probability of
my space being too big
is at most a half.
We're back to coin flipping.
Every time I flip
a coin, if I get
heads I have the right amount
of space at less than c times n
space.
If I get a tails I try again.
So the expected number
of trials is 2 at most
not trails, trials.
And it's also log n trials
with high probability.
How much time do I
spend for each trial?
Linear time.
I choose one hash function.
I hash all the items.
I count the number of collision
squared or the sum of lj
squared.
That takes linear time to do.
And so the total work I'm doing
for these steps is n log n.
So n log n to do
step 1 and 1 prime
and log squared n to
do steps 2 and 2 prime.
Overall n Polylog
or polynomial time.
And we get guaranteed no
collisions for static data.
Constant worst case search
and linear worst case space.
This is kind of surprising
that this works out
but everything's nice.
Now you know hashing.